en la región montañosa del estado de río
de janeiro ya están en marcha los
funerales de las víctimas del mortal
deslizamiento de tierra del martes los
familiares de las víctimas como
auditorias ramos que perdió a su padre
en el desastre aún no asimilan la
tragedia
no parece cierto todavía es algo que es
difícil el día estaba tan hermoso en la
mañana nadie esperaba la lluvia
[Música]
todavía es difícil poner en palabras lo
que estoy pasando
qué está pasando
en la localidad turística de petrópolis
a 68 kilómetros del río de janeiro donde
el 15 de febrero se produjo el derrumbe
provocado por las intensas lluvias
muchos siguen en paradero desconocido
estoy aquí porque mi esposa me envió un
mensaje de las 6 y 16 a mi teléfono
móvil y a las 6 y 16 le respondí estoy
seguro de que está aquí porque el vecino
de abajo dijo que estaba en la terraza
cuando vino la avalancha y se lo llevó
todo
la búsqueda de sobrevivientes se ha
convertido rápidamente en una cacería
contrarreloj para recuperar los cuerpos
de las víctimas las lluvias fueron las
últimas de una serie de tormentas
mortales que azotaron brasil en los
últimos tres meses el presidente de
brasilia y el bolsonaro visitara
petrópolis este viernes y se comprometió
a llevar ayuda federal a los afectados
que quedaron sin hogar y desempleados
por el desastre